[music]
to bring back
the crusade [singing]
and then his newest book which is what
we talk about today which is called the
two swords of Christ five centuries of
war between Islam and the warrior monks
of Christendom and so it's a very very
interesting conversation I wish I had
more time with him but he's on an
incredibly tight schedule but guys
without further ado let's get into
Raymond Ibrahim, welcome back to
Undaunted Life of Man's podcast.
>> Hi, Kyle. Good to be with you again.
>> I'm always excited to talk to you, but
then we kind of get into some dower
subjects, and this is going to, you
know, not be an exception whatsoever
because I do want to talk about your
newest book, which is absolutely
spectacular. So, I'm chomping at the bit
here. But most of your public work, at
least from where I've been sitting, is
about Islam, but not just about, you
know, studying it, trying to understand
the five pillars better, and, you know,
becoming an apologist for that
worldview. It's more of an expository uh
job that you're doing. You're trying to
expose the world to exactly what is
going on within Islam and what they
actually mean versus what they say
publicly or what their PR firms do for
them. And even as we sit here right now,
Raymond, there are people that are being
targeted in Nigeria and Sudan and Mosamb
beek. There are Christians that are
being beheaded, raped, burned alive, all
kinds of different things by Muslims
simply because they are Muslims and
simply because the other people are
Christians. And then we have a bunch of
people trying to explain that away. And
so I guess let's talk a little bit about
what seems to be, you know, a lot of
your life's work and into what we're
even seeing in modern day.
Yeah, absolutely. Um, I got into this
entire field mostly looking at Islam
specifically from an academic point of
view back in my early days in college.
Um, and a lot of it has to do with my
own ethnic background being my family's
from Egypt were Coptic Christians which
is the indigenous inhabitants. So
obviously even from my youth I had an
interest in how Islam and Christianity
interacts. Um, and yeah, that's uh been
my is my my my point as you as you were
articulating it pretty well has been
just to really try to be as objective as
possible and show what Islam's really
all about because the current narrative
the way it's been presented by really
all channels from the academic world to
media to Hollywood has presented a very
uh whitewashed is putting it mildly
version of Islam. Okay. And um so and as
someone who has been immersed in the
study of Islamic history and Islamic
doctrine and who's been exposed to uh
original language sources of course um
that's just not the truth what I've seen
what has been presented. So much of my
life's work as you put it has been to
really offer correctives uh just as
objective as possible and people think
that I'm uh you know intentionally
trying to demonize Islam. I'm actually
just presenting the truth the way it
was. Um, and people think that because
what they're used to seeing is a
completely rosy picture. So when someone
like me presents something very
different, they think I'm, you know,
just I'm being mean. I'm I'm pulling I'm
I'm demonizing it in a word. Um, but
like I said, no, I'm just trying to be
as objective as possible.
>> Well, Islam doesn't need anyone to
demonize it for Islam because de, you
know, it demonizes itself essentially.
And so I I've even heard this quote here
recently. I I can't remember who to
attribute to, but it's society at large.
They essentially treat Christianity like
it's Islam. They treat Islam like it's
Christianity. And I even look at now we
have a lot of young liberal women of
course unmarried that are kind of like
Islamic adjacent or they're they're at
least soft towards Islam. And so they
want to they want to berate
conservatives about this supposed
Handmaid's Tale society that they live
in. But it's like oh I'm sorry you're
not wearing a burka right now. You
actually have rights in this country and
yet you're being soft towards Islam. I
mean, can you aside from demonic
activity, I don't know that I can
provide an apologetic for that, Raymond?
>> Yeah, and that's not a bad
interpretation, but um that's really the
point. It's bad enough that much of
Christian history has been suppressed
and demonized and Islamic history, the
opposite. And it's but it now has gotten
to the point because of that that it's
it's not just ignorance, it's actual
topsyturvy logic. So the the religion
and the civilization that has
historically been to use your example
oppressive of women until the present
and that's the ironic part it still is
and people see it with their eyes uh
that's still presented like this somehow
you know gentlemanly I suppose or that's
favorable towards women whereas
Christianity which is the number one
civilization that actually promoted
monogamy and respect for women is now
supposedly seen as the evil misogynistic
religion and so that's the dangers of
fake history that I've been tackling for
decades.
>> Well, and that's one of the reasons why
I love to have you on the show is
because your work I I've dug so far into
your work and the the amount of first
person sources and as you say original
language sources is substantial and
that's certainly true of the new book.
The new book guys is the two swords of
Christ's great name. Five centuries of
war between Islam and the warrior monks
of Christendom. And so this is actually
the third book in a trilogy a fantastic
book. book. So, you had Sword and
Scimitar, which I think was 2018. You
have Defenders of the West, which was
your first appearance on this show, and
then now this one that has just come
out. I want to read a a quote. Uh, I
think it's a very important quote from
your author's note. It really sets the
tone for the book, and then we'll get
into it from there. So, here's the
quote. While many modern Christians
believe their faith begins and ends with
being passive and non-confrontational,
turning the other cheek, never judging,
and being tolerant of everything,
including unadulterated evil. These men
took into account the tried uh and tried
to act on all of Christ's words. Take
Jesus's talk of swords. He tells his
disciples that he hath no sword. Let him
sell his garment and buy one. They
respond, "Lord, behold, here are two
swords to which Christ can see or
concludes, it is enough." We see that in
Luke 22. Whereas most modern-day
Christians allegorize the this verse
into meaninglessness, for most preodern
and especially medieval Christians, its
meaning was clear. Christians are to
fight two swords of evil with two sorts
of swords. A spiritual sword against
spiritual enemies and a physical sword
against physical enemies. Taken
together, these two swords were and are
enough. And so, Raymond, I mean, what a
powerful way to start this because, you
know, when you look at the cover and
you're kind of reading the thing, you're
like, "All right, this is going to be
kind of a history, maybe some crusadish
type stuff and maybe some cool stories
of valor." No, this sets the tone and
this is a major sticking point for a lot
of the men in our audience. I got a text
this morning. A guy said something in a
in a church group text that was a little
abrasive, a little aggressive. And one
of the other guys was like, "Hey, man.
Let's settle down. Let's cool a little
And it's just like we've gotten to such
a pussified version of Christianity in
modernity that would be completely
unrecognizable to a Templar knight or to
a hospitaler or a crusader or something
like that. So, but to start generically
and then we'll dig in, why this book?
Why now? Why you?
Well, this book uh actually I I wrote it
sort of like what you were alluding to
on the one hand because I'm interested
in history and I'm interested in that
nexus between Islam and Christendom, but
also to actually show modern day
Christians what how earlier Christians
really thought and how completely
different it is from modern day
Christianity. And the problem is what
we're you know I I've coined it years
ago what I what you're describing this
phenomenon you know of the pacification
as you put it. Um I call it doormat
Christianity which is is so diffused, so
widespread and so taken for granted by
your average Christian that this is the
you know the meaning of the gospel which
is basically as as that quote that you
read um you know you just everything
about Christianity is just turning the
other cheek to tolerating quote unquote
anything and everything no matter how
evil patting yourself on the back and
then saying look I'm a good Christian
when you're really actually you know
enabling evil and being a coward and um
never ever ever physically hurting or
engaging in physical harm. And that's
actually a very important point which
I'm hoping to develop at one point which
is that the reason so many modern day
Christians think this way is because
despite themselves and despite what they
say they're materialists okay so which
basically means just like a secular or
an atheist person they you know they'll
say they believe in the afterlife and
soul and the spirit etc. but they really
cling on to this life and the material
as if this is all you got. Um, and so in
that context, of course, it makes sense
for a Christian to think that if you
kill someone, that's the most evil thing
possible. But for preodern Christians
who actually believed in Christianity
and believed in an afterlife and in a
soul, the human life was not that
important. Life was short, brutal, and
nasty. you know to quote a later author
Hobbes and Leviathan but medieval
Christians certainly knew that where
everyone was you know if you every death
was a very common thing they knew
they're going to die um so actually
fighting back to prevent evil and to
protect the innocent even if you kill
someone wasn't actually seen and this
goes back all the way to Augustine um
you know in the context of just war
theory so that's why and without this
kind of thinking Christianity would have
died a long long time ago people don't
get that if you if you read as your my
other books sword and scimitar defenders
of the west and you see the unbridled
assault on Christendom that went on
century after century and that actually
in the in the context of Islam swallowed
up threequarters of the Christian world
okay and if they hadn't I have a quote
in one of my books I think defenders of
the west of Teddy Roosevelt who said
basically what I'm saying which is if
Christians didn't fight back there would
be no no Christianity is that Christ's
message is that what the doormat
Christians think we should do keep
turning the other cheek until
Christianity is completely and utterly
snuffed out. Um, so you know that's so
the two swords of Christ and that's why
that well that's why that title came to
me. Um, and it came to me because that's
what they talk about. So the Templars
and the Hospitalers and all those
medieval Christians like I have a lot of
quotes in there. They often cite that uh
Jesus's verse about the two sports and
it's true. Think about how modern day
Christians today allegorize it. I mean
what does it mean? It means nothing.
Literally, it means nothing to them
because on the one hand, Jesus says, "Go
sell your garment and buy a sword."
Okay? And they say, "Here's two." And he
says, "Okay, that's enough." And then
now, what what does that mean to a
modern day Christian? It means
absolutely nothing. It it just uh oh,
it's not a real sword. But for other
Christians, okay, that makes sense. One
sword, spiritual warfare, one sword,
secular warfare, which are both needed
to preserve, you know, Christian
civilization and to bring on God's
kingdom here in the now. because that's
actually how earlier Christians thought
of Christianity. It wasn't just I'm
going to live my life any which way and
oh I'm saved and then when I die I go to
heaven. It was actually about bringing
God's rule now in the now. Um and that's
how they thought. So of course you have
to have law and order in Jesus himself
you know to go back to just war theory
and I talk a little bit about it. Um
it's based on his own actions and words.
So it's not forget if you put away the
two swords verse you know he engaged in
violence in the temple. He made a whip.
He He got violent. Okay, so Jesus got
violent. And when Jesus was one time
slapped, he didn't turn the other cheek.
He actually challenged the man who
slapped him. Okay? And then there's so
many other examples when the centurion
comes and and Jesus performs a miracle
for his um his suffering servant. And
usually what Jesus does after he does a
miracle for someone is tells him repent.
He didn't tell this guy to repent even
though he was a centurion in the Roman
army, which means he has a lot of blood
on his hands. Same thing with John the
Baptist when soldiers came to him
saying, "What must we do?" He didn't
say, "Leave the army." He said, "Be
content with your wages." Um, so it's
unfortunate that they've and I believe
this idea, you know, this doormat
Christianity, of course, you know, the
tolerance and the love and the
forgiveness that is part of
Christianity, but it's balanced by what
I'm talking about. But there's a lot of
evil forces that hate Christianity that
have promoted this particular idea, have
pulled it out of context, and have
turned it into Christianity. And you've
gotten so many people fall falling for
it that it's become taken for granted.
And and as I sort of alluded, it doesn't
hurt that it's the easy kind of
Christianity, too, because it's not easy
to stand up. It's not easy to be
confrontational. It's not easy to fight
back. And it's not easy to, you know,
uh, sacrifice your life like these men
did. um it's a lot easier to say, "No,
no, I'm a good Christian. I'm a doormat.
I do nothing. I acquies and I'm passive
and therefore I pat myself on the back
and say I'm saved." So, it's all those
forces combined and and we can talk a
little bit more. Uh, you know, that's
that's the background of why of of the
writing this book, but we can get into
the actual history now.
>> Well, Raymond, I mean, I I remember
Jordan Peterson saying this uh several
years ago, but it's like, hey, if you're
a harmless man, that doesn't make you a
good man, it makes you worthless, right?
And so I I debated a a how would he put
himself? He's a pacifistic anti-gun
Christian advocate. His name is Shane
Clayborn. And I just smash him to pieces
in this debate because basically what I
proved, which I didn't have the the
words for at the time, is there's
technically no such thing as a pacifist.
There are people that are willing to
outsource their violence and people that
are unwilling to outsource their
violence. So for me, I'm unwilling to
outsource my violence, especially to the
local magistrates because if they ever
turn on me, I don't want to be dependent
upon them. Right now, I'm all good for
calling the cavalry, right? So someone
breaks into my house, honey, call the
police, daddy's going to work, right?
And it's just kind of one of those one
of those moments where this this idea
when you read about the crusaders, the
Templars, the hospitalers, it's like I
mean, gosh, it'll put some lead in your
pencil. As I'm reading this book, I'm
sitting there like, I'm the biggest wuss
on the planet, right? I do I even
believe in Jesus because I'm reading
about what these guys are doing. And so
I I think one thing that might be
helpful, Raymond, because we're going to
get we're going to get into a few
stories because we don't have a ton of
time. But as t as I talk to people about
your work and I'm taking a group of guys
in jiu-jitsu through sword and scimitar
right now.
When people say the Crusades, they they
think about it like the Civil War, the
World Wars, like okay, it happened in a
very truncated period of time in a very
small area. They don't realize there
were multitudes of them. They watch one
Orlando Bloom film and they think, okay,
that was the Crusades, right? And that
didn't even do a good job.
>> [clears throat]
>> But if you could just even give us a
highlevel overview of the breadth of the
crusades and then we'll get into I guess
a highle overview of the Templars and
the hospitalers because that we really
got to set the stage for what we're even
talking about here.
>> Sure. So the best way to start off with
the crusades is the way that nobody does
which is by giving context. Usually
people just started at 1095. Pope Urban
calls for the first crusade and you know
and and it's because it's a power play.
I've often quoted John Espazito, a
professor at uh Georgetown University,
and that's how he presents it. And he
says, "Literally five centuries of peace
between Muslims and Christians went by
until 1095 when quote permanent." So the
the quick summary and background is that
um when Muhammad dies in 632, one
century later in 732, his followers, the
Muslims had conquered,
you know, the it could be at that point
2/3 or closer to 3/4 of the Christian
world, which again people are and where
was mostly centered in what we today
call the Middle East. It was in North
Africa from Morocco to Egypt and it was
in in Middle East, greater Syria and all
the nations in that region and also of
course Asia Minor what we call Turkey.
That was the the heart of the Christian
world. Um people think Christianity is
Europe. Okay, you had five centers, five
major seas. Only one was in Europe,
Rome. The other four, Antioch,
Alexandria, Jerusalem, and
Constantinople were in the east and all
got conquered and swallowed up by Islam.
Okay. Um, so that one century between
Muhammad's between 632 and 732, I picked
that year because that's a battle of
tours. And so at that point, Islam had
conquered that entire area and is now in
the middle of France, uh, engaging in
jihad essentially. And that's what the
sources describe. And this goes on and
then another newer iteration comes on
right before the Crusades. And it's what
prompts the Crusades. Sorry about the
cat. [laughter]
>> No, we'll leave it in. We got a couple
of cats playing defense right now.
>> There you go.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm kind of used to it by now,
but um
>> All good.
>> So, right before the first crusade in
1095, um you have the Turks, the rise of
the Turks, especially in the guise of
the Seljic Turks, and now they are
running causing havoc in the Holy Land
especially and in Asia Minor. that this
is this is the process of turning
Christian Asia Minor which is you know
figures prominently in the New Testament
as as one of the oldest and earliest
Christian regions. This is the process
of turning it into Turkey. Okay. Um
right before the crusades. So you the
sources are talking about massacres of
tens of thousands of Christians,
Armenians, Georgians, Greeks, uh
Syrians, Syriak peoples and um also
assaults on pilgrims from Europe who are
going to the Holy Land. they're being
raped and killed and everything. And
that is what gave rise to the first
crusade. Okay. U the battle of Manzuker,
one of the major battles where really
opened the way for the Turks to start
colonizing Asia Minor was in 1071. And
between that year and 1095, matters just
kept getting worse and worse. And then
the the Eastern Roman Empire Emperor um
Alexius called on for help from the
West. And when you actually look at what
Pope Urban said, he's describing nothing
but atrocities being committed against
Christians, churches being destroyed and
plundered. Um, you know, in Armenia,
thousands of churches, which one it's
the oldest Christian nation, were
actually ritually desecrated and
torched. Okay, so this is the backdrop
and this is what gives rise to the first
crusade which happens in 1095. And
Christians in Europe are riled by
learning what's happening to their
eastern brethren and what's happening to
the holy supplr the most important
church in Christrysendom which is built
above uh or was built above the site of
Christ's burial, resurrection etc. And
so the first crusade is born and it's a
mass movement and uh you know they you
know long story short it is successful.
it does achieve its um objective
liberating Jerusalem and then after that
you know the the problem with the
crusades which people don't seem to
understand and a lot of people like to
you know say oh the Muslims you know
kicked their butt because the Christians
were weak it it because it was it was a
religious thing it was ideological it
wasn't conquest it was about actually
getting a particular piece of land the
holy land so what that meant is they the
crusaders were always isolated and
surrounded in a sea of Islam okay
Muslims didn't do that well Muslims did
is they actually would conquer peace
meal whatever is adjacent to them and
they always had their full full force
and reserves and supplies right there
because it's their land on on their
land. They're on the frontier. They
conquer it, they annex, they
consolidate, they move on to the next
spot. So they always have their entire
reserve body of force right there.
Whereas the crusaders were just like
plucked out and thrown into a sea of
Islam. And that's really the story of
the Crusades. It's vastly outnumbered
forces constantly being belleaguered and
attacked by hordes essentially. And so
the so so you the the numbers of the
crusades is second, the third etc. And
they go on usually till nine is the
numbers that they give are just um you
know reiterations. Uh something
especially horrific happens in the holy
land to the Christians and there's
another call and Christians go. But in
between these formal numbers that
historians give them, the crusade was a
constant. In other words, pilgrims,
which is how they saw themselves, armed
pilgrims, were constantly leaving Europe
and going to pilgrimage and help fight
and defend and keep the Holy Land. So,
it always goes on and but anyway, it
essentially, again, I'm giving you the
basic historical summation. It in 1291,
that's the end of it because that's the
the final stronghold, this the siege of
Aker and uh the the crusaders are kicked
out by the Mluks from Egypt. And that's
uh that's technically the end of their
you know major presence in the holy land
but they but still they try again
especially the templars and the
hospitalers and you know it's it's still
in their mind for centuries for for
Christians all throughout Europe that
they want to Christopher Columbus
centuries later right in 1492 everyone
knows he you know sailed looking for
spices they tell us actually if you dig
into sources this was part of the holy
war it was a crusade against Islam it
was the same thing there was a reason It
was Ferdinand Isabella that commissioned
him because they were hardcore crusaders
in the reconista of Spain and one of
their major uh the east was completely
flooded by Islam. You can't travel
without being slaughtered or enslaved
instantaneously. So they wanted to
actually go around circumvent Islam
whether it was the Ottomans or the
Mamluks in in order to actually find
aid. There was this there were all these
theories pressed for John you know some
supposed great king living somewhere in
the east. they would go and ally with
and then try to attack and crush Islam
in between them and re get regain
Jerusalem. So my point is this was a
constant for many many centuries uh but
it did end more or less according to the
historical narrative in 1291.
>> Let's go and talk a little bit you
brought up slavery there as well.
Another one of the things that's kind of
memory hold to history is is apparently
people think that only child slavery in
America is that's the only uh slavery
that ever occurred, right? But in the
book, you do take a little diet tribe
and talk about that a little bit to
where it's like, okay, the European
transatlantic slave uh slaving was, you
know, that was cold business is how you
talked about it. But Muslims would
enslave Europeans, white Europeans, and
it was fueled by their hate for them as
infidels, right? And and also this this
ignores the fact that most of the
Africans that were put into the African
uh the transatlantic slave trade were
captured by other Africans, right? So,
you know, when you talk about
reparations and things like that, it's
like, okay, if we go back to the source,
it's like, are you a descendant of an
African slaver? Are you the descendant
of an African slave? I don't think we
want to open up that can of worms. But
you do talk about in this book that
there were just so for every one Muslim
that was enslaved, uh, there were so
many multitudes of Christians that were
enslaved by Muslims. But again, you
don't hear about that in your world
history courses in college or high
school. that's never brought up in any
of these de debates on reparations or or
slavery or racism or any of those types
of things. But slavery is like the
lifeblood of of Islam in terms of how
they control the infidel and how they
basically that's another form of warfare
for them.
>> Yeah. Slavery is just part and parcel of
Islam. It is the only reason it it's not
being practiced in the Islamic world
openly is because it was banned by those
evil Christian Europeans who actually uh
on the one hand of course they did um
participate in slavery as you just
described because everyone did and
everyone enslaved everyone. Whites
enslaved whites, whites enslaved blacks,
blacks enslaved blacks and blacks
enslaved whites and everyone in between.
So it was just that's the way it was.
Um, but at least to their credit,
Christians in Europe, primarily in
England, are the ones who spearheaded
the abolition of slavery around the
world. Even though as of today, there's
something like 40 million slaves, most
of them in Africa and in Asia. Um, so
you know, slavery is back, but it's
primarily underground. Um, but it is
definitely part of Islam. It's part of
it's it's part it's in the Quran. And if
it's in the Quran as a legitimate thing,
you know, and people complain. But the
New Testament, well, all the New
Testament does is tell people, it's a
stoic message. It's basically if you are
a slave, be content, live your life, you
know, don't, you know,
>> and most of the words, most of the time
slavery is discussed in the New
Testament. The word is dulos, which is
bondervant, which would be someone that
was voluntarily giving their life and
their years to somebody, usually to pay
off a debt or because they couldn't care
for themselves. This wasn't one tribe in
Africa going into another village,
stealing all the people and killing uh
most of the men that were actually going
to fight back and then putting them in
chains and putting them in cages next to
the beaches so that the Europeans could
come and easily pick them up. This was
like a a super macob form of Uber Eats
that was happening back in the day. You
know what I mean? And so it's like it's
just it's just a generalized ignorance
of the entire process. Oh, it was it was
in in in in West Africa that was a major
industry and a lot of the Africans who
would enslave other Africans were
devastated once slavery was abolished
and they and and they became totally
impoverished because that was their
lifeblood was actually enslaving fellow
Africans and enslaving them and selling
them. So yeah, this is uh and this, you
know, this topic you bring up of slavery
is a perfect example which I discuss
often in general of fake history and how
it's being weaponized and used to
demoralize, you know, demonize and um
and just essentially destroy western
civilization by by convincing it that
its ancestors and its ways which were
good um were evil. So now you have to be
the opposite. And this and this goes
back to the Dormat Christianity. If it's
always if if western civilization in
history had been is so bad, especially
the Crusades, then you need to be the
exact opposite. Okay? And um so for
example, I often point this out in
Germany in in the year 1999
uh which marked the uh thousand-year
anniversary of the recapture of
Jerusalem at the hands of the crusaders.
I don't know, a mass pilgrimage of
Christians took off and they were all
wearing shirts that said in Arabic, "I'm
sorry." [laughter]
Okay? because they're apologizing for
those evil crusaders who dared go and
fight and reclaim Christian territory so
that Muslims don't rape, slaughter, and
kill Christians. Okay, that's uh so
that's because of this weaponization of
fake history and convincing Western
people and especially Christians that
their predecessors were the embodiment
of evil and you must be the antithesis.
That's why you see so much of what you
see.
>> Well, that's a new shirt idea for
Undaunted Life. We'll do sorry, not
sorry, but in Arabic and then uh so
we'll see how that one sells. But one of
the things we've talked about the
different forms of warfare and the
different ways that that Muslims and
again guys you got to go get a copy of
the two swords of Christ cuz I mean you
get into such good detail about the
importance of Constantinople and roads
and and aker and Malta and all these
different places that really really play
into all this. But one of the other
warfare tactics that is used by Muslims
is misdirection. So I'll use a quot a a
short quote from the book here. In
short, generation after generation of
Muslims pretended to be and lived as
model Christians in Spain even as they
had nothing but hatred for Christians
all to remain and eventually reconquer
Spain for Islam. Okay. So when you go to
the teachings from either the Quran or
the Hadith, you would see that Muhammad
would basically say like, "Yeah, lie to
your capttors, lie to the people that
are around you and just lie and wait,
right? even let them take a bite out of
you, but just lie and wait until the
time comes. And I, as I was reading your
quote, I was thinking about America. I
was thinking about the West large. So,
think of Europe, Canada, uh, the United
States, and how we've kind of tutted
Islam again. We treat it like it's, you
know, Christianity even though it's not.
And, you know, we kind of treat it as as
opposites or whatever. And people are
like, "Well, look, the only people that
I know that are Muslim, they're all
peaceful." It's like, okay, not all
Muslims are violent, but Islam is
inherently violent. And do you know that
that person isn't just following the
dictates of Muhammad from the Hadith or
the Quran to the letter, which is
basically like, hey, lie and wait until
the moment to expel the infidel comes.
And so that's what I'm I'm worried about
a lot of people in my audience, the the
rise of mosques all over the United
States. Entire cities in the United
States being taken over like Dearbornne,
Michigan. You have an Islamist, not just
a Muslim, but an Islamist Muslim
communist, now uh the mayor elect of New
York City. So, what's your read of all
this in terms of how we're treating
Islam in the West, especially in light
of how Muslims have acted in these
different places for hundreds of years?
>> Yeah. I mean this is the the answer is a
culmination of everything we've been
talking about which is this is the
complacency of the west because it's
been so browbeaten demoralized and it's
convinced you know the only virtuous act
is no act other than acquiescence and
and being a doormat and anything else is
evil well that's why uh you know
different hostile foreign civilizational
groups are taking over right beneath
their nose you know it's I often marvel
at the fact that when you look at you
know European or to be blunt. White
civilization, white people are such a
tiny minority, okay, of in the world.
And depending on the numbers you look
at, I've seen it from something like
five and 6% to maybe 9%. And yet that is
the only civilization that is being told
left and right and bombarded with a
message that you need to suppress your
culture, you need to suppress your
civilization, you need to suppress your
religion, and you need to welcome
everyone into your land and basically
uh, you know, move away. So everyone who
used to live in California now goes to
Idaho or something like that. Okay, it's
a constant retreat. Or look at what's
happening in Europe, places like in the
UK and Scandinavia and in general. So
the unfortunate thing is all those white
people, they still see their all they
think of is their own country, which
they're still the majority in. But
actually in the context of the world,
you're a tiny drop. And uh those people,
okay, they're not being told that
message. They believe that their
civilization, their religion and not
just Muslims, okay, just people in
general is superior in their language
and everything. They would never let you
come into their country and take over.
So you have this really perverse
situation where 90% of the world which
is very uh h you know confident in its
ways and would never ever think about
letting a minority come into its country
and change its country. They're being
allowed to come into the tiny minority,
the West, and the Westerners are being
told they have to, you know, do
everything to accommodate. So that's how
perverse this situation is and suicidal.
And people just don't get it because
again, they're living in a bubble.
They're living in a in a fake construct.
Their perception is totally false. It's
based on the media. It's based on
Hollywood. Um, and so yeah, it's uh
it's, you know, the concept that you're
referring to, Taya and Islam and and the
deception and all that. Yeah, that's
just part of the religion. And Muhammad
himself did preach it, okay? Which is
basically b your time. And uh I often
tell this anecdote when I worked at the
Library of Congress. I I knew a Muslim
and we were on friendly terms and he was
a serious Muslim and we would debate and
talk and um I would point out to him the
fact that because it's in the Quran
itself, the Quran itself is understood
as having two phases. One is when
Muhammad is weak and that's when he
preached actual tolerant verses. So the
the Muslim apologists when they quote
verses like you have your religion I
have mine there's no compulsion in
religion that's from Muhammad's weak uh
weak phase which is called the Mecca
phase and then he goes to Medina and
becomes essentially a warlord and that's
when he gets the violent verses which is
you know kill and slaughter them
wherever you find them etc etc. So, I
was pointing that out to him and uh you
know, and he kept saying, "No, no, Islam
is moderate. It's peaceful." And but he
finally, you know, dropped the veil and
showed that he knew what was going on
because he finally threw his hands up
and said, "Well, what do you want from
me? I'm living in Mecca." So, [laughter]
his point being,
>> I'm in the Mecca phase where I have to,
you know, I'm outnumbered. I have to be
talking about Islam as peaceful. And the
the inverse of that is, well, once uh
Muslims are strong enough, then it goes
to the more violent phase. So yeah, lot
lots of unfortunate ignorance. And the
worst part of all though is it's all by
design. None of this is organic. This is
completely intentional by those people
who do control the media, who do control
Hollywood, who do control the powers
that be. This is an intentional message.
Even the people who are who are behind
these false heretical Christianities
which are all about being a doormat
again. You know what what's what better
way to disarm and weaken a Christian
than by telling him, hey, your religion
is about doing nothing except whatever
and letting me do whatever I want and
then you you're a good Christian. Well,
of course, that's the most prominent
kind of Christianity and it's being
funded probably by non-Christians all
around the world because that's the best
way to get Christians to think to
actually enable your own agenda. when
it's mind-blowing to people that, you
know, you'll you'll watch a Muslim like
on a college campus or something like
that, you have these man on the street
things. They'll be like, "Oh, Islam
means peace." It's like, "No, it means
submission." And then they will quote
some of those uh Meccan verses, right?
Some of the the more peaceful verses,
but it's like, "Okay, let's go to the
least abregated text in the entirety of
the Quran." Basically, here's kind of my
last salvo to humanity and to my to my
brethren. It's Surah 9, which is the
bloodiest probably of all the suras. And
so it's like, okay, if that's the game
that we want to play, let's go to the
source material. Now, there are so many
good stories in this book, Raymond, but
we we are on short time, but there is
one story that I want you to tell us.
And unfortunately, I'm guaranteed to not
pronounce this guy's name correctly, but
it's Jacqueline Dele
Jacqueline Demali, something like that.
So, so if you could just tell our
audience
>> Yeah. If you could tell us that story,
it's incredible.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's a great story. And um
it's basically so one of the verses that
really biblical verses cuz remember
these military orders, the knights of
the temple and the hospital, they didn't
pull this out of you know unlike what
the Christian modern day Christian
charges like those weren't real
Christians. They were engaged in
violence. No, they actually read and
studied the Bible and they believed in
the Old Testament as well, which is as
militant as it gets. So in Deuteronomy,
there's a verse that talks about how if
God wills it, one man can stand against
a thousand and two can put 10,000 to
flight. And the idea is that, you know,
it's not about numbers. And this is
actually why so many crusaders would go
and throw themselves into that sea of
Islam because they had faith that it's
not about numbers. If if I'm doing if
God's on my side, then we can win. So
that verse was really taken to heart and
was often quoted in their documents and
their charters. the Templars and the
hospitalers. I have a lot of I talk a
lot about it in the book. St. Bernard
was a chief proponent of it. And um so
there was a a major battle that went on
and the crusader and the crusaders were
completely outnumbered. It was typical
and um they got crushed and they were
killed. I think it's the battle of
Croissant. Um and one night, you know,
he could have he could have um
surrendered. He could have run away.
Some did. One night's Templar that is.
Uh this this battle featured a small
group of uh I think it was like 300 and
uh but maybe a hundred of them were
Templar knights. Okay. And 200 were what
were would be called secular knights.
They were all killed. But there was one
man left standing who you just
mentioned, Jacqueline of Malay. And uh
and and and he's described in the
chronicers as being motivated by that
one verse. And even the Muslims were so
amazed by him that they started
according to the source affectionately
telling him just surrender because they
were impressed by his prowess. And um
there's actually I I included a picture
of it. Well, here's the book by the way.
>> A great painting. Yeah, it's a great
painting in the book.
>> Here's a book and I'll just show you a
picture because it was this is one of
those heroic things that was once upon a
time known but now isn't for some odd
reason. Um, instead Hollywood gives us
fake nonsense when even when we actually
had uh, you know, there was reason to be
impressed by the real thing. So, I don't
know if you can see it. There's uh, do
you see that?
>> Yep. Absolutely.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's him basically surrounded by,
you know, hordes of Muslims and he
wouldn't surrender and he was riddled
with arrows. his horse was riddled with
arrows and um then he finally died and
he was celebrated as a martyr uh you
know by his comrades by by historians
because you know why is he a martyr
because he's actually fighting for the
faith he's fighting in defense of
Christianity he's fighting in defense of
Christ and his followers okay so that
was actually that's why crusaders
thought of um crusaders who march and
die as martyrs because think about it
they would actually also quote the verse
where Christ says no greater love does
man have than does he have and laying
his own life for his fellow men as
Christ did. Of course, Christ did it in
a grand cosmic sense. But these guys
also did it in their own humble way by
trying to defend and literally selling
their lives to protect the lives of
others.
>> Well, Raymond, it's a tremendous
trilogy, Sword and Scimitar, Defenders
of the West, and the Two Swords of
Christ. But you know how it goes. You
binge watch an entire season of a show
and it took you the weekend and it took
them three years to make it and edit it.
But it's all, "What have you done for me
lately? What are you working on next?
So, is there a fourth book in the
series? Are we taking a hard left turn
in our work? What's next for you?
>> No, no. I'm uh [clears throat] what I'm
I'm currently in my little break time
deciding what's next. But there's
definitely going to be many many more
more books, God willing. And they're
going to there this theme that I've been
addressing um especially not just Islam
and Christianity, but more uh you know
res re reclaiming sort of masculinity
and Christianity and the defense spirit
and so forth. That's pro my next book
will probably be dealing with that. Uh
you know the concept of just war theory
in I mean I've talked about these before
but a real deep dive into how to reclaim
what was once there and is now lost.
>> Well Raymond, you're always going to
have an audience with my audience. But
that's all for me. Is there anything
else you want to get off your chest?
>> No. The book comes out uh pretty soon.
Uh anyone you should try to get it. I
think you'll like it. It's uh for the
record, all my other books, and this is
an oddity that I I only found out, but
three of my last books are 352 pages
each exactly, which I never planned, but
this one is 512. So, and this book, just
for the record, because in my other
books, I touch on the Crusades. Some
chapters deal with the Crusades. This
book is is the one that most deals
entirely with the Crusades because the
Templars and the Hospitalers were the
backbone of the Crusades. So there was
no getting around covering virtually
every crusade in detail because there
were that's the only way to talk about
them. [snorts]
>> Very good. Well, Raymond, thanks again
for coming on.
>> Thanks, Kyle.
>> Who's got the [music] guts to bring back
the crusade?
[music]
Bring back the fight.
Bring back the [music] flame.
Bring back the fire in the rightous
name.